and today I can confirm the next stage
of our jobs retention scheme this scheme
has been a world leading economic
intervention supporting livelihoods and
protecting futures seven and a half
million jobs have been furloughed jobs
we could have lost if we had not acted
nearly a million businesses supported
who could have closed shot for good
and as we reopen the economy we will
need to support people back to work we
will do so in a measured way I can
announce today that the job retention
scheme will be extended for four months
until the end of October by that point
we will have provided eight months of
support to British people and businesses
until the end of July there will be no
changes whatsoever then from August to
October the scheme will continue for all
sectors and regions of the UK but with
greater flexibility to support the
transition back to work
employers currently using the scheme
will be able to bring furloughed
employees back part-time and we will ask
employers to start sharing with the
government the cost of paying people
salaries full details will follow by the
end of May but I want to assure people
today of one thing that won't change
workers will through the combined
efforts of government and employers
continue to receive the same level of
overall support as they do now at 80
percent of their current salary up to
two and a half thousand pounds a month
Mr Speaker I'm extending this scheme
because I won't give up on the people
who rely on it our message today is
simple we stood behind Britain's workers
and businesses
we came into this crisis and we will
stand behind them as we come through the
other side thank you